hallo leute und herz bekommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
ich habe heute zwei ganz besondere gäste
stellt euch mal selbst vor
ganz genau die beiden sind meine
ehemaligen nachbarn aus der heimat ich
dachte mir einfach per kopf für kinder
gern mal was ganz spannendes und ihr
könnt eure wünsche gesagt wollte früh
gibt es in lettland apfel normales
kostenschub richtig super alles leider
geht's los also im prinzip gibt es ja
nicht viel was ich machen muss ich mal
das komplette andere sachen konnte ich
nicht unbedingt selbst machen ich habe
gute croissants ich schneide als alle
erstmal hier den schnitt lockt wie
sieht's bei euch aus jungs seid gekocht
ihr auch gerne ja wozu vor allem oder
immer ein geht und du kannst du bist du
auch schon mal sparen kochen oder dass
du das lieber den moritz die mir helfen
wird
ich habe schon mal kommst ihren molly
waren beide schon mal auf dem kanal von
meinem bruder da waren die aber noch ein
bisschen kleiner ich werde jetzt hier
mal ein kleiner ausschnitt ein wir haben
zwei gäste heute am start und zwar
einmal ja molly und die liebste in der
zwischenzeit bis größer geworden
mit dem bald sehen das ist knackig
schnell noch mal ein bisschen klein wir
haben auch tatsächlich was sehr
ausgefallen ist heute noch auf dem
menüplan stehen und zwar ist es eine
fränkische spezialität schäufele
das ist also zum braten aus der schulter
vom schwein machst du qualitätstest und
ich noch das kommt noch nicht unterwegs
schon sehr gespannt
für ein bisschen überrascht als ihr euch
das gewünscht habe ich eine willkommene
chelsea übrigens nach und ich kürze hier
einfach mal so die bacon streifen die
ich gekauft habe ich mache ich später
noch was mit dem grillen da brauche ich
den weg für dein körper passiert kann
ich den belgischen aber das versteht man
uns nicht mehr so gut wenn es so laut
ist oder braten jetzt fordert er das ist
gut weil da hat natürlich im gesicht
sondern wohnzimmer dem feld nach wir
schon knusprig werden probieren
französisches kommen der zu machen das
ist noch mal so ein bisschen speziell
nach den feier
vier stück konzipiert sie mal kurz für
das video der meetings zeigen ist ein
guter musik gemeint war wissen
überrascht lässt sich heute reinkommt
danke dir kommen sie diesen song
vorgespielt hat aber für mich sehr cool
okay heute wir gehen jetzt ein wenig
butter in die pfanne lassen die ein
bisschen an schnitzen
die gehen jetzt das eigene fahne und so
weit drin ist müssen wir hier die pfanne
und fernwälder so konstant in bewegung
halten so wenn das dann jetzt durch
geworden ist lassen das stehen auf der
hütte und ein bisschen an backen so und
jetzt geben wir oben noch die krise so
und jetzt leute ist das ganze schön
angefangen jetzt gehen wir da ein
bisschen drunter welt kannst du mir auch
irgendwann mal ein hamlet kommen die
wert schaffen wir jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen nach vorne dass wir die
unterseite aufbau klappt müssen wir hier
so ein bisschen lappen und jetzt haben
wir hier drin ein schönes on labs spaß
auf wieso ein rap oder symbole
jetzt müssen wir das nur noch
[Musik]
doch auch mal die youtuber gerne leute
es ist jetzt so weit kommt sie hatte
schon ordentlich und hat sich schon als
auch morgen kannst hier auch gerne was
nehmt ihr euch was ab genau nimmt sie
dann einfach über auf trab ihr könnt
jetzt einfach mal in ruhe probieren und
euch durch alles durch die sehen das mit
dass arbeit und dann hochladen sogar mit
der hand genau probiert euch nicht alles
durch und ihr müsst schon jetzt die
ganze überlegen am ende wenn ihr
aufgelöst hat müsste mir eine note die
entweder 0 punkte wenn es ganz schlimm
ist oder das beste szene ist das jetzt
ganz und wo wir machen jetzt mal die
kamera aus und dann könnt ihr mir gerne
sagen sie jetzt fragt also was note 10
von euch beim check dann kommen wir auch
schon zum mittagessen es gibt bürger
die jungs haben sich bürger gewünscht
ich mache dir wieder mit dem prior
spannungs war es sind einfach die besten
bürger nötig ich mache gerne meine smash
burger ich werde jetzt probieren die
quasi vorzubereiten also quasi 80ern
mädchen nur dass ich die dann schon auf
backpapier presse und da kann ich die
aber trieben gleich auf den mündigen den
gärten
conti ist total hinterher dass sich
viele abos gefühle ich hab jeden teil
du kannst so oft sagen wie du willst ja
dann würden wir jetzt hier erstmal das
burger fleisch vertrauen kommt sie
möchte hier immer gerne die kamera über
dem feld erstmal kurz wackelt dann wisst
ihr bescheid was los ist hast du schon
mal selbst burger auch macht es nicht
klappt nehmen wir mal so kunden
europäischen fünf bürger machen wir fünf
welchen habe ich hier vorbereitet ich
form die einfach mal grob zu kugeln und
ich drücke jetzt die kugeln hier drunter
einfach ein bisschen platt haben wieder
so machen wir schnell die pfanne und
dann mache ich den becken können ja auch
schon kalt eingeben
nee das war schon gut wenn das licht
anders helfen fehlen er konnte die tür
sagen wir machen will draußen weiter
dann können wir das ganze auch schon
drauf legen dem bericht zufolge dafür
dass parallel hatte sich hier schon mal
die bürger brötchen ein bisschen an und
dann wenden wir auch in die partie
wir machen das jetzt kurz zu und bieten
und bitte ihn kein nachfärben auch eine
seite ordentlich auf die andere seite
mario auch die mayo seite liegt der
gurken und dann schleppen es auch schon
das partie
alles klar jungs dann ist es auch soweit
lasst es euch gerne schmecken kann kein
haus könnt ihr dabei schon mal ein
bisschen sagen okay es lecker findet
oder nicht
auch ihn verbrannt ist wie band sind ein
bisschen ein bisschen viel farbe
bekommen
kloten ist aber tatsächlich ein bisschen
wir kommen zur bewertung rating ein
fahrzeug zu führen ote 10.10 gibst du
mir und du einen neuen pächter noch
einen neuen hype einigen ja so wir
kommen uns auch zum abendessen ihr seht
schon möhren zwiebeln und hier drüben
ein fertiges stück vom schwein und zwar
schulterschluss nennt man hat das hat
sich moritz gewünscht wir sind hier in
unterfranken und dementsprechend ein
bisschen traditionelle küche mit
eingeflossen
ich bereite als erster linie die möbel
vor dir einfach kurz würfel die ganz
grob die kommen quasi mit in den topf
während er im ofen hat vor sich hin
berät geben uns dann für die soße netten
geschmack wir stehen mann los
drei großen chören der wir das ganze
land mit knödel der dem ist ungefähr 1
esslöffel in den kopf hinein alles was
wir jetzt machen spielt sich in diesem
top up das ist in so einem breiten topf
genommen die gesagt die karotte grob in
stücke schneiden das reicht so schon
gleich nach möglichen auch hier
so einmal drüber lässt sich die spanne
leichter lösen halbieren effekt findet
ihr auch anfassen also gehen wir jetzt
dass wir mit rein aber einfach nur so
passiert so sieht unsere schäufele aus
normalerweise hat das unten dran noch
ein knochen also ich hätte das ganze
jetzt diagonal ein und das gibt am ende
so eine richtig schöne kruste wie in so
einem bierzelt oder einem wirtshaus
haupt so sieht das ganze land aus und
dann beraten jetzt auch schon kann von
allen seiten außer von der oberseite wo
die schwarze sitzt die schließlich
nämlich sonst und wird nicht mehr
knusprig am ende und das müssen wir
natürlich behindert jetzt haben wir alle
seiten durch schöne röstaromen 1
bekommen und dann gehen wir auch schon
so eine miese dazu so ich habe vergessen
das ganze zu kürzen aber das ist gar
nicht so schlimm wir uns jetzt einfach
noch mal rauf wir brauchen weil das
natürlich ein bayerisches gericht ist
brauchen wir kümmern dass wir genau
richtig besorgt und dann nach salz und
pfeffer ein bisschen drüber ziehen und
der konzentration
ich kann jetzt dabei schon darauf achten
dass die schwarte und möglichst in einer
ebene liegt ich gehe jetzt mal hier in
unserem top noch ein bisschen rinder vor
dazu
das freut mich allerdings so wie mir das
ganze jetzt in den backofen nein das
zusperren
so und jetzt mach ich hier das leid
thermometer an und steckt damit zu den
braten nein so dass wir so
kerntemperatur abnehmen können und so
bleibt das ganze jetzt im ofen bis die
kerntemperatur erreicht es ich weiß
nicht genau wie lange das braucht ich
schätze mal so zwei drei stunden
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen butter
schmalz war nach zwei hände voll
brotkrumen geschnitten die fress dich
jetzt so ein bisschen sinn an und hier
ist ein vorbereiteter kloßteig dann
völlig gleich die klöße in der hütte mit
ein paar angerosteten brotwürfel also
rein geben weil hier das wasser fängt an
zu kochen
hier sind ihr angerosteten zu sammeln
und dann nehmen wir uns jetzt einfach
hier vom kloster davor man jetzt in der
mitte gibt da zwei drei größeren dadurch
werden ihnen er mich ja erstmal den
klöster ins wasser hinein und warten
dann bist du auch wenn wir uns eine
kerntemperatur von 77 grad und jetzt
öffnen wir hier die tür ohne die
schwarze nass zu machen schütten wir
meint ihr dazu damit verhindern wir
quasi dass die schwarte noch weiter gas
geben der saucen leckeren biergeschmack
machen jetzt gleich die hitze noch etwas
höher sondern weil wir dazu jetzt drehen
wir also die hitze was hoch auf 230 grad
und kein temperaturen müssen wir noch
weiter
ihr seht hier leute das wird dir zu
popcorn artig oben auf der brust und das
ist genau das was wir wollen
das kommt natürlich dass wir das ganze
ist nur bei hoher temperatur von oben
mit oberhitze anrösten und dadurch wird
das ganze auch schon knusprig so leute
da kommt jetzt der topf aus und es sieht
sehr sehr schön aus wenn ich eine schöne
knusprige kruste obendrauf jetzt wenn
wir nämlich hier den teufel raus dann
legt einfach das ganze als zehn minuten
ruhen und jetzt stelle ich die soße in
das epub schon lecker und dann lassen
wir das ganze jetzt nochmal auch voller
power hier aufkommen so die jetzt ist
jetzt ein bisschen runter jetzt gehen
wir ein bisschen soßenbinder dazu also
stärker
wir haben jetzt unseren braten den
schneide ich jetzt mal schön alles
andere ist nämlich so weit fertig ein
bier ich das ganze hier gucken mal rein
oh ja auch sehr schön dann halte ich
hier nochmal und das sind jetzt die zwei
schönen stücke die wir servieren oder
unfassbar sagt ich gibt richtig gut auch
[Musik]
lang genug gewartet dann lasst euch mal
schmecken schäufele dein lieblingsessen
wir müssen den ganzen teller aufessen
oder so viel wirtschaft und das mit dem
ich bin okay dann sehen wir gleich
wieder so jung ist ja auch gegessen das
war doch mal eine ordentliche portion
oder hat es euch gut geschmeckt sehr gut
was findet ihr am leckersten teller
alles für eine gute habe die sparte von
scheufelen okay das freut mich sehr also
ich muß schon mal sagen es hat mir echt
spaß gemacht heute mit euch einen tag zu
verbringen für euch zu kochen und ihr
habt ja gerade schon gesagt ob ich
morgen auch noch hier bleiben kann und
machen kann
wer das cool
ich muss aber leider noch ein bisschen
auch das video schneiden und deshalb
kann ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen
aber wenn ihr mal in köln seit seit ihr
wie gesagt bei mir herzlich eingeladen
wie sieht eure wie sieht eure
bewertungen aus licht an sich eigentlich
20 ganz auf ihr können wir nicht machen
glaube ich 20 nehmen wir mal die zehn
ich würde euch sagen dankeschön es freut
mich dass euch super geschmeckt hat die
war echt coole der save super heute noch
was sagen zum abschluss wird ihr
vielleicht jemanden grüßen heynckes wir
dann bleib ich so auch immer grüßen
die frage wird gegrüßt macht's gut leute
schild
[Musik]